- Hi, I'm Lenny Lipton;
this is my dog Belle.
- [Narrator] Lenny Lipton is
sitting in his living room.
- [Lenny] Puff the Magic Dragon
- [Narrator] Reading something
you've probably heard.
- [Lenny] Lived by the sea and
frolicked in the autumn mist
in a land called Honalee.
♫ Puff the Magic Dragon
- [Narrator] Lenny wrote what has
become the stoner's anthem.
- [Lenny] I wrote Puff the Magic Dragon.
- [Narrator] When he was a
19-year-old college student.
- [Lenny] I was a freshman at Cornell.
Belle can you sit?
Thank you dear.
Okay, I was reading a poem by Ogden Nash
called Custard the Dragon.
- [Narrator] Soon after he went
to meet friends for dinner.
- [Lenny] As I was walking
down the hill to the apartment,
I was thinking about the poem I read,
and I thought I'd try to
write one too, about a dragon.
- [Narrator] He got to
his friend's apartment
and let himself in.
- [Lenny] I saw a typewriter
on a kitchen table,
and I typed "Puff the Magic
Dragon lived by the sea
and frolicked in the autumn
mist in a land called Honalee."
And although I didn't find out about
this for a couple years,
Peter Yarrow, who became the
Peter of Peter, Paul and Mary,
was one of the guys who
lived in the apartment.
He saved the poem.
I completely forgot about it.
I even left it in the typewriter,
and he set it to music.
That's how the song got
written and it changed my life.
(upbeat ukulele music)
- [Narrator] But Lenny's
story doesn't stop there.
- [Lenny] I've got
something like 72 patents.
I invented the way to project 3-D movies,
you're likely to see if
you go to the cinemas.
- [Narrator] He also invented
those awkward glasses
you have to wear to see them.
- This is crystallized, this
is the first commercial pair
of 3-D active electronic eyewear.
- [Narrator] And everyone from NASA
to James Cameron has used them.
- NASA on Mars and Cameron underwater.
- [Narrator] Lenny is also a filmmaker.
He's produced over 25 movies.
- It's a lifetime achievement award.
- [Narrator] And he's written
several books all about,
well, film and one autobiography.
- But I don't think it's of interest.
My wife read one chapter
and she said she didn't
want to read any more.
(Lenny laughs)
- [Narrator] Okay, so
a book about his life
is not his magnum opus.
Good thing a song about drugs is,
cause that's what it's about, right?
- If people want to think it's about pot,
that's fine with me.
- [Narrator] Wait, it's not?
- Not as far as I'm concerned.
Puff the Magic Dragon is not about drugs,
and who knows, who knows what I was thinking?
♫ Lives in a land called Honalee